When i first started programming I was
pretty intimidated by all the new jargon
that people were using.
When I met people that introduced
themselves as programmers, developers or
coders, or when they said words like
front-end, backend and data analyst,
I'd always ask, so what do you do again?
On top of that, I wasn't even sure about
how coding will impact my daily life.
Is really hard for
me to see how learning programming
would affect me in my current role.
But then I started realizing how
the knowledge of programming can
enhance different people's lives.
Here's some examples.
A restaurant owner is able to build
his own website in HTML, CSS and
JavaScript to advertise
his business online.
He might even be able to use Python or
Ruby to take customer orders.
A program manager that works with
software engineers, is able to
understand the technical components
of a project and analyze data.
A teacher may be able to create
a mobile app to remind his students
about homework that's due the next day.
Or an artist is able to put up
a responsive portfolio online for
clients to see.
As a dancer,
I realized that I needed a way to share
my work with local dance companies.
Once I learned how to code, I created
a website for my dance portfolio.
I didn't consider myself
a programmer at the time, but
coding really impacted my role.
Programming skills can impact anyone.
Let's hear from Liz about how her
new skills have impacted her.